the people we've moved so far away from
the Constitution that in many ways we
don't even recognize it we think that
we're becoming more advanced by
abandoning the Constitution and adopting
something like an administrative state
but what we're in fact doing is becoming
more primitive we are regressing the
boundaries were trying to create a
regime of Liberty usually would be the
greatest possible private scope of
freedom while at the same time being
based upon the basic moral principles of
the natural law and natural rights the
rights of life and liberty and the
pursuit of happiness these are rights
that you have because you are a human
being they're not rights that you have
because government decides to give them
to you the idea then for just government
and the only reason you would consent to
government is because government secures
those rights the people who make the
laws are people too how do we know they
won't make them in their own interest
you need a constitution and it needs to
be in control of the government almost
everybody in America even people very
different perspectives census there's
something deeply wrong with our
political recovery of the earlier
constitutional understanding I believe
it's useful to help guide us but at the
very least we have to understand in
order to know what relation should we
have to that today the Constitution is
in the service of a larger set of
principles and that when we abandon
those principles not only do we have a
different understanding of Rights but we
also abandon constitutionalism
I'm Kevin Porteous I'm Thomas West I'm
RJ post Rideau I'm John Graham this is
Constitution 101
[Music]